I want to talk about the number 15 in
English but it's not English that you
know this is going to be Celtic English
before the Romans came here so it's not
going to be English that comes from
German lines I dry one two three this is
the the form of English used by
shepherds to count their flocks
and I've spent quite a lot of time Brady
learning how to say Yan tan tether a
peddler pimp for one two three four five
well as young tan tether app either a
pimp pimp is five I find that quite
nicely amusing and then it's cetera
letter a' hoverer cover a dick and then
you get on to the next numbers which are
Yan a dick because it's one and ten
janna dick can addicted a dick better a
dick and then it's bum fit so 15 is bum
feed and and if you want to take
anything away from this it is a pimp
plus a dick is a bump it and then you
get Jana bump it Tanner bump fit death
or a bum fit pepper a bum fit fig eat
tether a date so they're a bum
fit leather a bomb figure and hang on
ice like I get a notch in mistake now
this changes depending on which part of
the country this is the Lincolnshire
version if you go tit down south it's
more refined
so it's yin pain tether a pivot so this
is five sheet plus ten sheep equals 15
now all right there's a little bully
thing with a head out here and let's
toes
he's coming along alright this is a pimp
plus a dick I can't even say it right
dick is equal to UM feet in some part of
the countries that has two T's but and
that's not really relevant at all so you
have up to 20 so a pimp plus a dick plus
another plinth pimp is a figured
they get to figured they get to twenty
sheep and they couldn't cope with that I
mean that's hard enough to do and it'll
keep you awake so if you're actually
counting sleep sheep
this way you'll keep awake rather than
nodding off and then they put a stone in
their pocket so a twenty they stop a
twenty and they start counting again
with a stone in their pocket or a marble
or they might draw a line on the ground
and then they would go the same thing
again for the next twenty so this is a
base 20 system which is not very good
because you you have to rely on
something else in order to count up to
maybe 80 or 100 because they want to
take their sheep over somewhere else and
flog them off and know the numbers and
they want as many as possible people
keep it going but there was a tradition
until about 1900 where the farmers and
the shepherds were still using this so
it became part of the culture written
down and so there's a record of this not
a television record but a record of it
so that people know about this system
and it's different in different parts of
the country including Scotland including
Wales yeah yeah I find as I get older I
am mature with age